congratulations on the movie thank you
thanks David I wanted to come your way
first because I was reading the Disney
first approach to about this film when
you were winding down on Pete's Dragon
so it was making me wonder what would
you say is the biggest difference
between how you picture the film turning
out when you first committed to making
it and then what we see in the final
product now that's an excellent question
I I think it is quite similar to what we
had in mind
in that it is it feels real it's got the
rush and the scope and the the sense of
adventure that that no pun intended
hooked me from the very beginning and it
has the the depth of character that I
was yearning for when I thought of like
how would I tell this story but there
are so many things that I could never
have anticipated there were so many you
know twists and turns the project took
over the years that you know I just
could not have uh you know dreamed up
back then whatever day in March of 2016
that I signed on to this and the
the joy of of working on something for
this long this is certainly the longest
I've ever worked on one thing is seeing
those watermarks along the way of seeing
how it develops seeing how it changed
seeing how I changed as I made this film
just to get an example there can you
share something that changed over the
course of that process that now we can
see uh influencing the Finish film
certainly when I set out to make the
movie initially I was like let's do a
90-minute Peter Pan Adventure movie hits
all the Beats we're in and out and it's
just like Fast and Furious not like
literally Fast and Furious movies but
like that we just keep moving
and then at a certain point we realized
let's slow it down a little bit let's
start to ask questions about these
characters because I was starting to
feel curious about them and that led to
a lot of the
wonderful new material we've got about
hook and Peter that when I first when I
first went into the studio and pitched
my take that certainly wasn't on the
table but it became so it became the
centrifuge of the entire movie in so
many ways and that was
that was a process to get to that point
oh I can't imagine this movie without
that and that gives me a perfect segue
to go to you now Jude so we do get the
the necessary information to support the
story that this movie is telling but you
guys open up a pretty significant door
to a lot of backstory for hook that
we've never explored before so did you
do any backstory work on your own or
come up with any little details that
maybe we don't see or hear about
directly in the film but we can feel
informing your performance that you hope
viewers pick up on well vote you know I
was very lucky in that an awful lot of
it is is is ultimately explained in the
brig uh scene with with Wendy and um
and so
that I I don't remember I mean we we
talked a lot about all of the Mac story
in detail as we in pre-production and
there were just tiny little details or
or confirmations between the two of us
that okay this is how it happened
um but but beat by beat it's pretty much
as described by by hook
um and
I suppose what was what was most
interesting was then taking okay if
that's what happened then then then how
has that affected who he is and what he
is and what he looks like and of course
suddenly you take an idea or you talk
take a story and it suddenly turns into
something three-dimensional and fleshed
out and and then you start thinking
about well
actually playing that
is very different to imagining it
playing someone who is sort of locked
into this childish childhood rivalry in
the body of a sort of 50 year old man
who has seen and lived and done Terrible
Things is a really interesting area to
start playing you know
um and uh
I I was just conscious that I wanted to
bring in all the elements I wanted him
to be sad I wanted him to be scarred and
gnarly and disgusting and scary and and
funny too like a sort of an overheated
Angry Dad or Uncle who who from a kid's
perspective is just really pathetic and
and loud you know and there were so many
little details that supported that such
as
I don't know if you remember but the set
was full of of your cabin was full of
all these drawings that hook had made of
ways to maybe catch capture Peter Pan
they made something yeah they were like
little catapults yeah and crossbows
crossbows and balloons with Nets in and
I mean just this guy like I've got to
get this boy I've got to get him yeah
there was also I don't know if you yeah
you see the collection of hands yeah the
collection of hands and jars jars yeah
where he's obviously tried to sew
something back on you know I love
looking for all those little details now
I have a reason to go back and watch it
again
do your Captain Hook as a True Villain
Like A person who was destined to find
himself on a darker path eventually or
is he is he a man who was basically
forced to become one just completely
reshaped by the influences around him I
think the latter I think the latter and
I think what's extraordinary about this
version is that by the end he's
he's been on a journey where he's
allowed to retain the best parts of that
which is you know the sort of yin to
slip to Peter's Yang without the hatred
I mean it's very interesting that he
gets to say hope at the end that his
hope is oh I can keep playing but maybe
well as Peter says with that without
such a bad game like Peter says I don't
like this yeah you know it's it suddenly
that perhaps not the Jeopardy but the
threat goes you feel it all right I want
to squeeze in one unrelated question
before they make me leave you guys about
Skeleton Crew and I'll throw this to you
Jude because you get to work with an
exceptional lineup of directors there
David included so is there anything you
could tease about maybe the consistent
style and tone of the show but then also
how those very specific voices that
we've come to love and know so well are
going to be able to shine through that
as well I think like like Disney uh or
like a uh an extraordinary uh Legacy
piece of work like Peter Pan and Wendy
by Jay and Barry or like Star Wars you
know
great great storytellers writers
directors actors all have their version
their interpretation of that what it
means to them and it's incredibly
malleable you know but you've got to
stick to certain rules but it's very
very malleable
um and what was wonderful was seeing how
all of these formidable directors
brought their
their signature their their tone to it
and yet it was always in that world and
that world is you know can withstand a
huge amount they've done it before I
believe they're gonna do it again with
Skeleton Crew I look forward to that
congratulations on this I cannot wait my
new thing now that I have a niece and
nephew is that when I see movies like
this that I know I can share with them
and they'll appreciate it just it fills
my heart and this is not perfect that
makes me enjoy it it makes me so happy